hi I'm Shari pie and I'm at BuzzFeed
Squier Prague this is my first prom
[Music]
[Music]
for me being here for queer prom feels
like a well-deserved break I'm
officially done with high school and
ready for whatever the world throws at
me and that's excited I'm like most
excited to see everyone being
comfortable with everything that they're
wearing Oh a raucous ooh I want you to
look at me like dang she look good I
want to be seen
I'm gonna look and keep looking and then
not look away the whole Mike I want to
do expose spotlights I get to do that
for one survivor that's so cool to me
[Music]
the hair everyone's positive vibes and
the makeup home I am I both like royalty
to be completely honest I do love the
attention a little bit
everyone's experimenting with makeup
with clothing I I like looking like a
boss I like looking put together and
like I get to our pants
that's awesome always prints like this
yeah I got chills as soon as I put that
jumpsuit on I'm excited about that I
can't wait to see all of it oh my god I
hope you like at home I could go
somewhere in a pink tux oh my god yes my
hair look good i look full always if the
rest of my life is going to be like this
or anywhere close I am so ready
I feel so confident what I'm wearing I
feel confident my hair I feel confident
my makeup my clothes I'm wearing
something I'm gonna be comfortable and I
don't wear pants and getting busted move
why not I'm so excited to wear this to
queer prom
[Music]
I'm super particular about the outfits
that I've put together and I ended up
looking like exactly how I wanted to
look Wow like this actually happening I
get to wear a boutonniere I get to wear
whatever I want
you're gonna see like the true IVA
you're gonna get the whole attitude I
mean like be like extra extra read all
about it
it was amazing walking through the
streets dressed up so fancy and have
everyone just like staring at us
we looked amazing we looked great we
just looked like an entourage and we
were important people
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey everyone I'm Jay Manuel and we are
here at BuzzFeed Squier prom welcome to
quick I did I absolutely did not have it
where fun growing up but being here is
incredibly us all joining together on
the 1st of June Pride Month here in New
York City to celebrate queer prom when I
was on the red carpet I felt like I was
having the most fun with my friends and
that made the experience like 10 times
better
I thought the Samsungs base was so so
crazy we all did the coolest Samsung 8
through 7 experiences together like no
matter who you are it is absolutely
awesome it was just like.he service like
the perfect sanctuary to be rainbows
everyone knows I'm gay and it's okay
ready to party let's go let me
officially welcome you to BuzzFeed's
queer prom
and let's also give a round of applause
for a beautiful from Korres
you could be whoever dress however do
whatever and everybody's like yeah these
extra as you wanna because we're all
extra
I remember dancing lots of dancing being
very out of breath just everybody smiles
it was actually the first time that I
danced with my mom to get it good so I'm
putting on some dance last night it was
like that's like no that's not my child
they had never seen me dance before he
was out here she was getting it I had
such a good time
but drag queens of the highlight of my
night I've never seen people so
confident in themselves and I was so
inspiring to see drag queens make you
confident drag queens I'm ready for
everything there's a performance by star
Lee which is absolutely incredible I
think I love star Lee I definitely was
in a room full of people that would
respect me and love me no matter what
it's just you know I felt like a loved I
felt appreciated to say this news to you
um I guess I hang out with a bunch of
queer people that I never met before and
they honestly felt like family and um
this thing which I will never take off
my head I felt so good getting crowned
especially by curly oh my god I love him
I opened up something I never thought I
could I'm building that stepping-stone
for future generations to be able to
scream out loud yes I am gay or queer or
whatever you identify as having this
experience I realized how much of myself
I had been holding back so learning so
much about myself and learning so much
about what I can do
I don't know I felt like I was my full
self at queer prom and I can start
trying to be my full self in other
places in my life also
[Applause]
Starly let me sing on the microphone it
was awesome it was probably the best
night of my entire life other than you
know when I was born that was really fun
oh I always told the person that I was
10 years ago that things are gonna get
so amazing that you can't even imagine
it like I still can't even imagine it so
just wait it if I can go back in time I
would say uh-uh
why are you hiding the true you is
amazing and no one wants you to hide
that and there are people who are going
to love you for you so don't change for
anyone
I learned that everyone has a different
book everyone's got a different story
and no matter how you write your story
and you're always supported and have a
community because I would say to
preteens who are watching this video if
you feel alone right now I promise
you're not you can talk to me you can
reach out to me I will talk to you I
just love the fact that they were all
able to come there for one night and
just forget about everything else and
have a good time this was like a home
I'm probably gonna talk about career
from for the rest of my life what
existed at prom and the last couple days
needs to get out into the world
love you guys yeah see you later bro
it's just the start of something new
No
[Music]
[Music]
is Bobby